how's it going I'm Amy East fair weather
and incentive exercising you can just
turn off all the lights in your house
welcome to hashtag news audience
audience imma let you finish the new
media rockstars released its list of top
100 youtubers of all time ain't nobody
dun got no time to go through an entire
list in just a couple of minutes so
we're gonna focus on the top 5 and I'm
going to give you my in-depth analysis
along the way we all know why we enjoy
watching YouTube you want to see kinda
pop people tell us random stuff random
stuff but also we appreciate when the
content has a great message too that's
why coming in at number 5 is everybody's
favorite quasi albino Tyler Oakley
Tyler is whip smart charismatic super
sassy and has hair like a mood ring
what's there not to love honestly I'd
say he'd be my perfect match if he
weren't only 13 years old he's 25 he's
25 I guess there's nothing stopping us
from being together event even executes
card what Oh Tyler's YouTube's favorite
gay icon who did what he uses his
massive audience to spread the word
about difficulties LGBT youth face today
and raising awareness for The Trevor
Project an organization dedicated into
counseling teens dealing with depression
and lots of suicides so not only is he
adorably sassy but he's got a good heart
he's trying to make a freakin difference
in this world I'm in love with him up
next at number four is rooster teen I am
so but they didn't go with their
original name for the channel dentures
whoa what that's another name for
rooster hitch your minds out of the sexy
gutter rooster teeth it's pretty much
responsible for the entire genre of
films made using video game graphics you
might have seen their popular web series
red vs. blue featuring characters from
the game halo here's a clip hey cheat I
think NES is the best hashtag news hope
I've gotta agree with us she's also the
prettiest hey hey hey don't forget she's
they smile dance she's perfect
yeah perfect roosterteeth is also
responsible for the slow mo guys which
is completely different here's a clip of
that I love Anna
I love you too rooster dogs number three
Epic Meal toy if you've never seen an
episode of Epic Meal Time it's basically
this YouTube channel it's so stupid it's
smart you're not even ready for this yo
we start with the only country that
could produce such gangsta white boys
its Canadore gon america stock girls
gone wild but these are guys gone wild
covered in barbecue miles and no they
don't care about no recommended dietary
guidelines because they're manly men
bless it away the haters with the
Aviators they'll be defining what you
call food they got that Jack Daniels
Sal's running through their veins and
don't forget the most important mother
father of them all don't want me to rule
them all bacon bacon
don't make its call they can be I can
damn right playa how was that you guys
was that good thank you
up next the pen ultimate YouTube channel
of all time over two is jenna Marbles Oh
raspy-voiced female comedian with the
dash of crazy
I wonder where we've seen that before
okay I'm not gonna lie I'm super jelly
of Jenna she's the original in fact how
to trick people into thinking you're
good looking got me so many dates that I
did not deserve and if this were a
competition about being the most
hilarious girl with the most platinum
blonde hair the most masters degrees and
the most adorable puppies then Jenna
would take the cake not that she would
eat it because have you seen her apps
but this is about the best YouTube
channel of all time that means of all
history you guessed it up across fuzzles
these guys have shown us what would
happen if Darth Vader took on Hitler and
brought boats are back from the dead to
battle Skrillex
to celebrate these masters of time and
rhyme we threw a ticker-tape parade in
their honor thank you
thank you so much thank you thank you
hey you know what thanks I really thank
you another thing that is it's settled
those were the top five YouTube channels
of all time in a while I think I
presented a solid argument go ahead and
let us know in the comments if you think
anyone else belong in the top five to
check out the full list go to new media
rockstars calm and to see our very own
interview with nicepeter and epiclloyd
where they talk about what it's like
being on the best channel ever go to our
podcasts subscribe if you want to see me
do my Harley Morenstein impression at
your next birthday party
but until then I've been a nice fair
weather and this has been an epic
hashtag news